[موسيقى]
من هم خصوم تركيا المتميزون عند حدوثها
الجنوبيه شمال شرقي سوريا والذين تستهدفهم
انقر حاليا بضربات جويه ومدفعيه وقد تطور
الاستهداف الى عمليه عسكريه
تسيطر على مناطق شمال شرقي سوريا ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وهي تنظيم اسس
عام 2015 يتكون من فصائل ابرزها وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه وحدات حمايه المراه
اضافه الى قوات حرس الخابور وقوات
الصناديد وفصائل اخرى لكنه وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه وحدات حمايه المراه وهما
فصلان قوامهما مسلحون اكراد هما الاكثر
عرضا وتسليحا وتحكما بمراكز القرار
والقياده ضمن ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه كما انهما اقدم ظهورا ويشكلان
الذراع العسكريه لحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
المؤسس شمال الشرقي سوريا عام 2003 هذا
الحزب تصنف تركيا على انه الفرق السوري
لحزب العمال الكردستاني المعروف اختصارا
والمصن تنظيما ارهابيا فيصاليا لدى تركيا
واشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي القائد الحالي
لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلومه
عبدي نشرت له صوره في وقت سابق تقول
بشانها المصادر التركيه الرسميه انها تظهر
تبعيته ومعظم مقاتل الفصائل الكرديه في
سوريا لحزب العمال الكردستاني الذي شكل
نهايه السبعينيات القرن الماضي ويتمركز
قاده وكثير من مقاتله في جبال قنديل
الممتده عند الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
التركيه
مقاتل حزب العمال الكردستاني
وتفجيرات داخل تركيا
وداخل اراضيها بهدف القضاء عليه او الحد
من نشاطه على اقل تقدير